welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and dr strange and the multiverse
of madness released a new imax trailer
and this new widened aspect ratio
reveals apparently 26 more of each shot
so theoretically i should now be able to
find 26 more details right right because
easter eggs are always hidden in the
upper and lower margins of every frame
to a proportional degree well since
literally every pixel of this footage is
filled with madness i am here to tell
you hell yeah i scooby-doo this [ __ ] i
beat those odds and found 40 more
details than in my first breakdown and
that difference means my perception is
14
sharper than what marvel is willing to
show us with a slightly thicker angle
meaning the thicker we get the deeper i
go your cringe means you liked it let's
go first this shot of strange's
nightmare in front of that melting
sanctum one that i pointed out is
actually one story higher than the
sanctum normally is so this is some
nightmarish weird sanctum this shot has
now been widened so that the twisting
branches of that dead tree now creep
down from overhead all of these trees
are now more visible and in sharper
detail and they may indicate whether
this is truly a dream or something else
because with that red ring in the sky
these might actually be the trees of
wanda's grove that pocket reality that
strange finds her in now warped because
later in the trailer when strange who's
still wearing that same scarf goes from
that white blossoming grove to a red
tinted hellscape wearing that same
outfit behind him are similar twisted
tree branches this imax trailer also
gives us a new context to that odd blue
patch sewn into the back of strange's
cloak because in front of that statue
the widened anger reveals that the cloak
there is only burned at that point
doesn't yet have the blue patch and the
shot of strange with the dinosaurs there
too no blue patch just that dark burnt
spot so there may be some early conflict
that burns the cloak leading to him
getting it repaired with a new blue
patch perhaps from his buddies at the
illuminati then in the shot of sorcerers
defending comptaj from an explosion it
now looks like their golden eldritch
magic is being sucked upward if you go
through frame by frame before the
explosion rocks them as if this threat
is using their own magic against them
there is also two black aerial blips
flying rightward it could be great
odin's ravens or more likely to some
fleeing birds then in the shot of
strange conjuring red orbs from the dark
hole two new details in the shot after
this when strange slams the magic back
into the book the window behind him is
now unbroken whereas in the wider shot
the pains were broken so what is going
on here well the shot of him pushing the
spells back in the book might actually
be reversed he might actually be
releasing them and that release is what
breaks the window or maybe conjuring
these red orbs briefly teleports strange
into this darker more broken version of
the sanctum and if you look closely when
he shoves those spells back in to the
right you can see a chess set and i am
obligated to mention it because we now
have marvel's top chess player crossing
over into this universe and these two
must sit down for one game at least then
we see this shot of america chavez
running from gargantos and the shots
seemed so fixated on the star itself on
the back of her jacket as if that is the
bullseye target that gargantos's eye is
focused on almost like strange's blue
patch or even like loki's variant jacket
all these a bit of flair to mark the
fugitive and in this imax shot you can
now see adriana's deli there is an
adriana soria from marvel comics that is
the spider queen a telepathic mutant is
this a reference to her we don't know
yet but we gotta come back to the shot
of patrick stewart charles xavier which
by the way patrick stewart finally
admitted to in an interview with jake
hamilton i actually didn't recognize my
own voice it sounded different whether i
had a cold or something at the time i
don't know but i was astonished and all
they saw was the back of my shoulder and
i think my earlobe nothing else that
there would have been so many
connections made but i it it uh it
pleased me and here in the imac shot you
can see more clearly his seat back
separate from his shoulder meaning he is
seated as he glides forward probably in
his hover chair the deus actually has
six chairs with an empty slot in the
middle for professor x meaning that
there are seven members of the mcu
illuminati not six yeah as you can tell
i'm really making a meal of these easter
eggs too bad i can't really cook eggs to
save my life literally it would save my
life to be able to feed myself well huge
thanks to hellofresh for showing me how
to feed myself and for sponsoring this
video with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-proportioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door they make home cooking easy and fun
and affordable that's why it's america's
number one meal kit getting a
home-cooked meal on the table every day
is an accomplishment worth celebrating
let hellofresh help with 50 weekly menu
and market items to choose from so that
you can think less about what's for
dinner and more about how batman hides
his cape while he's on a motorcycle how
does it not get caught on everything
hello fresh is more 5 star reviews than
any other meal kit because the food is
delicious hello fresh's pre-proportioned
ingredients mean there is less prep time
for you and less wasted food it's also a
great value even at full price its
pre-proportion ingredients mean you
don't really waste any money on excess
food save those dollars for your cape
budget last night i made some amazing
pork tacos it took no time at all they
tasted so good i can't wait to recreate
it i felt like a pro chef look how happy
i was at the end of it it's taco time
so go to hellofresh.com and use code
rockstars 16 for up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts then in that shot
of american chavez and strange tumbling
pass to dinosaurs if you look closely
you can see america grabbing strange's
eye of agamotto and that is what
triggers their breaking into a new
reality and that break takes the shape
of a star as i explored in another video
the return of strange's eye of agamotto
in this movie may indicate this is the
second of three alternate eyes of
agamotto this one having a link with
america chavez and then on the other
side of that star portal yes is an
animated cartoon reality but we gotta
point out this is not the same animation
style as we saw in what if this is a
simpler flatter style something closer
to the 90s x-men which is coming back to
disney plus as x-men 97. then these
shots of this mystery figure fighting
wanda the imax version of the shot
reveals one is red chaos magic glow
around that rubble before the glowing
figure smashes through it reminding us
of how when wanda fought thanos an game
all that rebel around him got lifted
with him wanda loves to weaponize her
surroundings but more significantly in
the shot of wanda blocking the blow
behind her you can now see more clearly
one of the statues of this location all
of these hold these wing-like planks
almost like angel wings except here you
can see some kind of writing on the
edges of the planks still too blurry to
make out what it says but now it kind of
looks like these dudes are like the
bindings of open books also the one
right behind wanda has a kind of node on
his forehead almost like a goggles or
maybe a minor helmet light falcon does
have goggles these could all represent
different avengers even then in this
shot of the utopian sanctum with the
statue of supreme strange notice this
one has no goatee an absurdly high
collar major douchebag vibes but we also
now see more of his sanctum normally
that window is much higher on the attic
level but here it is lower on the second
floor and that brick wall around it
forms an eye shape making the whole
building a kind of eye of agamotto now
the window has always been on the higher
level to draw less attention to the
building from the street level so you
could walk right by it without ever
really looking up and thinking how weird
it is but here the window's right there
super noticeable right behind the even
more unavoidable statue but my favorite
new detail this shot of the two wandas
reveals more of the scarlet witch
costume the scratches on her chest
pieces and how right in the middle of
the collar there is an opening perfectly
in the shape of the mind stone from
vision's head kind of like a way of
showing how his mental presence lives on
in her heart then america chavez leaps
off this altar the back wall this temple
looks like the scarlet witch page the
dark hole and the altar itself has
ingredients of a ram's head as does the
cover of the darkhold book making me
think this could be the dark hold of
wundergor mountain where the elder god
cathan wrote the darkhold and then in
that mountain stayed dormant until he
returned to curse wanda with chaos magic
when she was a baby then as a sorcerer
battles gargantos you can actually see
some glowing runes on his tentacles
which match those of that ribbon entity
that attacked america chavez earlier
perhaps marking both of these beasts as
interdimensional threats that defender
strange in his squad must now wrangle
then in the shot of defender strange
blocking all those dark skeletons from
pushing into our reality above that rift
on the stone surfaces now more visible
in frame carved runes this may be the
mouth of the dark hold temple of
wundergord mountain but also and really
this is only noticeable in the imax
frame i think this black rift is in the
shape of a star almost like a five petal
flower opening or gets like an opening
hand if you think about it but this
being a star portal suggests that it was
created by america chavez in fact maybe
even that same punch she did from the
altar might have caused this rift and
might have been exactly what c'thon
wanted her to do so there you have it
that's at least 16 new things that i
found just by watching a bigger version
of this and considering i had uh 40
missable details in my first breakdown
16 divided by 40 that's that's 40 on top
of what i found before this is why i
love my trailers with curves
uh that's gross i'm sorry i'm gonna get
out of here so follow me on instagram
and twitter if you don't hate me at
eavos follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you